بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين اما
بعد رمضان
‏led
mirac perform by the propet عليه
ولم of course this is not all of
them as we mention time and time again
that listing the miracles of the prophet
الله عليه
وسلم is
entirely
tob du to
the she amount of miracles
عل
الصلام
however
well in the most accurate and authentic
sources which are the miracles
which الحافظ النوي رحمه الله
تعالى تهذ الاماء والغ
المد رح الله
تالى we are at the end of
these
led
mir hopefully be able to concl them
ton
and and back
up second
year حج
يقول الحافظ النووي رحمه
الله ودعا اي النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
لابن عباس ان يفقهه الله في
الدين فكان كذلك اصل هذه الروايه في
الصحيحين عند البخاري
ومسلم
و النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم دعا لابن
عباس كما انه
دعا لابي
هريره فدعا لابي هريره ان يكون حافظا
لحديثه فكان اكثر الصحابه حفظا لحديث رسول
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم على تاخر اسلامه
فانه لم يمكث
ا لم
يلبث مصاحبا النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم الا
اربع سنوات
ففاق من سواه في حفظ حديثه لتخصصه بذلك
ومن قبل ذلك لدعاء النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم له وكذلك ابن عباس ابن عباس كان من
صغار الصحابه فدع النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم له بهذا فكان ما دعا
له و have
دعا صلى الله عليه
وسلم بخاري
مسلم صلى الله عليه وسلم
دعا
اللهن عس
great ع
‏again
عس
was
high
gener ابن
عباس صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏because of that the time with the
prophet الله عليه
وسلم whil being of age to
comprehend very few years because his
father
him medina he was very young at the most
gener
could الله عليه
‏made his time prop صل الله عليه وسلم
exus
in however
in ابن
عس الله سبحانه وتالى
عن are those we know the
best with his
success عمر عثمن علي رضي الله
عنهم عبد الله بن مسعود
‏lik ابو مو الاشع
عبدن ابن الع and
his head of
عشه رضي الله
عنها عبن ع
‏learn and
col tradition of the propet الله عليه
وسلم
so عبدن عس
friends
him why are you spending so much time
gathering all of this knowledge
‏never come you
are
ma prop
علس and are here in
medina and it's unl that you really be
need and so
heed to learn
heed his
apprenti
عن and
‏maj
تعين
more عبد اللهن عس
was
considered عبد الله بن عباس
مه عبد الله بن عباس كذلك دعا النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم له بالف بالدين وكذلك في
التاويل خاصه في تفسير
القران جاء
في تفسير الطبري وعند غيره باسانيد
جيده ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال في
الدعاء نفسه اللهم فقهه في الدين وعلمه
التاويل فهذا التاويل هو تاويل القران
والتاويل هو التفسير في لغه الصحابه رضي
الله
عنهم فلذلك
لم
يفك ابن عباس احد من الصحابه
شهره
وعلما
ومعرفه بتاويل كتاب الله
فهو من ابرزهم ان لم يكن ابرزهم على
الاطلاق واليه منتهى
التفسير ولذلك كثر اصحابه وكثرت الاسانيد
عن ابن عباس
وكثر نقل
تفسيره وله المدرسه المعروفه مدرسه مكه في
التفسير وهي المعتمده وهي التي اعتمدها
البخاري رحمه الله
وكذلك الامام احمد والترم
وغيرهم صنفوا في
التفسير عبد اللهن
عس
مي he was given the schar in
me ع ع
‏exp قران understand
قران
now
قران is point i
overl
قران الله سبحانه وتالى قران
كب
مبين a c
and ب c in
clarifying the world around us and
clarifying
affs
however قران
also
exp
u منه ايات محكمات واخر متشابه
‏and so
these these ambiguous
verses they are
explained according to whom who is the
authority on what these ambiguous verses
mean the ambiguous
verses are taken advantage of by people
individuals groups
‏these
ues are always their
evidences for their innovation for their
transgression those who killed the
companions رضي الله عنهم
قران قران
ران those
‏even
act
الله
all قران are
ambiguous they taken advantage of there
is more than one way to understand them
now we have to understand
صلى الله عليه
وسلم الله سبحانه وتالى tell سور النحل
that sent قران down صلى الله عليه
وسلم
قران
and the
‏qu however there are as that
havei messenger and that is we the
propet الله عليه وسلم explain the قران
to the companions they are arab they
understand the قران however there are
aspects of the قران that have to be
explained they have to be
صلى الله عليه
وسلم
this n here which became biger and biger
as time went on because
people over
time
تير few
and blom ‏and become more and more and
more exp to where we
have volumes explain every aspect of the
the reas for that is people need that
now because of their distance and their
unf that they are unfamiliar excuse me
with the arabic
language عبدن عس رضي الله عنهما
وكان معظما مبجلا بين
الصحابه
لفقه
وللتاجر وممن صاحب النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم في
بدايات نبوته وهو ممن هاجر هجرتين وهو من
شهد غزوه بدر فما
بعدها
18 معركه كان فيها النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم او
غزوه فمع ذلك فعبد الله بن
مسعود يقول في ابن عباس نعمه ترجمان
القران ابن
عباس ابن عباسي
صل الله عليه
وسلم
said best
exp قران عبد اللهن
عس arrived and the cali which he ached
during the time of these elder رضي الله
عنه
وهذا من عظيم نعمه الله
عليه
وببركه دعاء النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم له
اللهم فقهه في الدين وعلمه التاويل
يقول ودعا على عتبه ابن ابي لهب ان يسلط
الله عليه كلبا من كلابه فقتله الاسد
بالزرقاء
الزرقاء موضع
بالشام وهذه
القصه قد
تكون مما اخطا فيه النساخ نساخ
الكتاب بعد النووي او سبق قلم للنووي رحمه
الله
لان
الذي كان امره كذلك في الحقيقه هو عتيبه
ابن ابي لهب واما عتبه ابن ابي لهب
فالمشهور عند المؤرخين انه
اسلم اسلم هو
واخوه واما عتيبه فهو الذي دعا عليه النبي
صلى الله عليه
وسلم ان يسلط الله عليه كلبا من
كلابه فجاءه اسد بري وهم في سفر في الشام
في الزرقاء وموضع معروف
و التقطه من بين القوم وذهب به ليلا وهم
نيام اسال الله
العافيه صلى الله عليه
وسلم صلى الله
وس
was
iric عتيب ابن اب
[Silence]
لهب عتنه
‏ifed الله سبحانه
وتالى chapter of
قران
being of
such
vicious
antagon being so
antag صلى الله عليه وسلم
عتيبه صلى الله عليه وسلم
دعا
الله
let
ofs
عت and عت was travel
‏as was mention by the
historians
this kind of it's kind of a desert
dwelling dog kind of aal
dog it came at night and it took him
while they were sleeping
now how is this a miracle
‏person to make
دعا
الله ch that happ ex
ex الله سبحانه
‏consistently every time throughout 23
span in different situations
some unexpected situ this now is that is
impossibility there is
more يقول ودعا بنزول المطر حين سالوه ذلك
لقح اوط المطر ولم يكن في السماء قزعه
يعني غيمه فثار سحاب امثال الجبال ومطر
الى الجمعه الاخرى حتى سالوه ان يدعو
برفعه فدعا فارتفع وخرجوا يمشون في الشمس
هذه روايه معروفه حديث انس في
الصحيحين ان
صل الله عليه
وسلم
خ
man
that they be given rain wasing time
dr
andy c as
‏was cloud in the sky and as the propet
عليه وسلم
raised hands and
الله that الله سبحانه وتعالى
suddenly sent and clouds were seen to
gather
and come
in mountains into the sky
انس رضي الله
عنه
معاين جاءه اعرابي وهو على
المنبر ف
سال منه ان يدعو الله سبحانه وتعالى
بالمطر وكانوا
في وقت قحط
وسنه فرفع يديه وقال انس حتى رايت بياض
ابطيه فدعا
بالمطر فلم ينزل من المنبر بعد
دعائه الا وقد
شهد
الماء يقطر من لحيته عليه الصلاه والسلام
لحيته
الكريمه عليه افضل الصلاه
والسلام
non
man صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
دعا ودعا لابي طلحه ومراته ام سلم ام سلم
هي ام انس بن مالك وابو
طلحه انس يكون ربيبه زوج ا ودعا لابي طلحه
الانصاري وراته ام سليم ان يبارك الله
لهما في ليلتهما فكان كذلك فحملت فولدت
عبد الله فكان من اولاده تسعه كلهم علماء
هذه روايه موجوده في الصحيحين معروفه وذلك
ان ابا طلحه رضي الله عنه كان له ولد صغير
يوعك كان مريضا
ف كان شفقان عليه كثير ابو طلحه وشايل همه
زي ما بقولوا
ف
خرج فمع خروجه توفي
الطفل فقالت ام
سليم لا يخبرن احد منكم ابا طلحه ولاكن
انا الذي اخبره فتزينت
وصنعت له طعاما فلما رجع قال كيف ابني
ماذا فعل ولدي فقالت هو اسكن ما
كان اسكن ما كان من السكون يعني ساكن جدا
صحيح هو
توفي
فظن هو ان المقصود ان المرض يعني خف عنه
فقدمت اليه الطعام
فاكل ثم اصاب
منها فلما ان
شبع
وانتهى من مقامه قالت له ام
سليم ان الله تعالى قد قبض
ولدك بمعنى ما قالت فغضب وقال تركتني حتى
اذا تلطخت واخبرتني بابني فخرج غضبا الى
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم فاخبره
الخبر فقال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
اعرست الليله فقال نعم قال بارك الله
لكما
فحملت وولدت
ولدا وكان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم عاده
الصحابه في
المدينه ان الذي يجيه
ولد يرسلون الولد الى النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم مع تمر فكان يمضغ التمر
ويحنكش يدخل الى بطن الولد ويدعو له
بالبركه
ويسميه فكان يسمي هو ابناء
الصحابه فسماه عبد الله
فهذا الولد عبد الله قرا
القران بمعنى انه حفظ القران فكان عالما
به ثم جاءه تسعه من البنين كلهم قراوا
القران وكانوا من العلماء فهذا ببركه دعاء
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم والحديث في
الصحيحين وموسع في صحيح مسلم
ابس م ان
his
prev
more was
‏seem he was ill clearly and
so to do out of the house and while he
was g his son passed
away and
so told the rest of whoever in the house
the kids and whoever is around her and
with her her rela don't
tell what happen i will tell him myself
‏so dred
very well and she made me and
ابه he
asked my she said he is as cal as
ever and of
course thought that this meant that he
was you know relieved of his fever but
really cm
‏and spent the evening with his wife
after
which told him that your son actually
has passed
away he got upset said you know you
didn't this from me and
‏kind guilty perhaps that he was eating
and enjoying not knowing all the that
his son passed and he was very att to
this youngy this young boy was old
enough to speak he
wasn't tiny baby
was وه
ال كناه النبي صل الله عليه وسلم كناه ابا
عمير الحديث في
الصحيح ما فعل النغير يا ابا
عمير كانت له كان له عصفور صغير كان يوريه
للنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم فقال ما فعل
النغير اللي هو الطير يا ابا عمير فكنا
هذا هو الولد الذي توفاه الله في هذه
الحادثه
انس انس رضي الله عنه ‏narrates this
narration muslim
that
hearing صلى الله عليه
وسلم in
حديث صحيح الباري صحيح
مسلم ضحين
عنصل الله عليه وسلم all
time happ
any and ask
him this is an incredible thing it's
almost unbelievable to think about
it
mak عن
‏this is it
a to with the companions رضي الله عنه
come up
op
that aged if they differed on something
for scholars to choose the correct f but
that is the soul aff of the
scholarship nor
‏exp and so for even the companion say
otherwise they kind brush
this this is a sign
incred incred
ignorance على كل حال
صل الله عليه
وسلم
and he
said that yes
they done a husb and wife do so the صلى
الله عليه وسلم made
د that night and said
الله give them and bless them what you
give them and
so later on she had a son
‏froment the usually
s newborn to the prophet الله عليه
dat date up in
inf us name
name ع ‏and made دعا for the and up to
beor
قران and considered of the schar of
medina and that boy انس انسن مك half
from
maternal
عبد children all which
يقول ودعا لام ابي هريره رضي الله عنه
بالهدايه فذهب ابو هريره فوجدها تغتسل وقد
اسلمت وهذه روايه موجوده عند الامام مسلم
في صحيحه وابو هريره رضي الله عنه كان
قريبا جدا من امه
وكانت لم تسلم بعد
الا انه لما هاجر جاءت معه فابو هريره ذهب
الى النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يشكو اليه
حال امه يعني انا امراه طيبه وكذا وكذا
لكن لم تسلم بعد و مهموم على المساله
فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم دعا
له دعا لها ان
تسلم ف رجع من تلك
المجلس فوجد الباب
مغلق فنادى فاذا امه تغتسل غسل
الاسلام وتخبره من وراء
الباب صلى الله عليه وسلم دعا ابو هريره
[Silence]
ابير was kind
neut as much ابو discussed isam with her
not
musl and he kind got a frustrated went
to the propet صل الله عليه وسم one day
this صل الله عليه وسلم
‏that gather and home to be locked and
he heard the splashing of water and his
mother
was you
know
شلام دع لام قيس بنت محصن اختي عكاشه بطول
العمر ف فلا نعلم امراه عمرت ما
عمرت وهذه الروايه يقول رواه النسائي في
ابواب غسل الميت
صلى الله عليه وسلم
دعاس
sister عشه
عشه
that صل الله عل
وسلم يعني النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ذر في
حديث الصحيحين في حديث ابن عباس
ذكر ان مع
امته سبين الفا يدخلون الجنه بغير حساب
ولا عذاب فقام عكاشه ابن محصن فقال ادع
الله لي ان يجعلني منهم قال انت
منهم فقام اخر فقال ادع لي ان اكون منهم
فقال سبقك بها
عكاشه عكاشه ابن محصن رضي الله عنه قتل في
او استشهد
في بعض حروب
الرده رضي الله عنه واخته دعا لها النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم بطول العمر
فلا يعلم امراه عمرت ما عمرت رضي الله
عنها ام قيس س
عكشه صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم
her a very life
and liv companion from among all
them رمى الكفار يوم حنين بقبضه من تراب
وقال شاهت الوجوه فهزمهم الله تعالى
وامتلات اعينهم
ترابا وشاهت الوجوه بمعنى
قبحت وهذا كان ايضا في غزوه بدر وقال
تعالى وما رميت اذ رميت ولكن الله رمى
صلى الله عليه
وسلم سيره وخرج على مئه من قريش
ينتظرونه ليفعلوا به مكروها فوضع التراب
على رؤوسهم ومضى ولم يره وهذه روايه ذكرها
ابن اسحاق في يرته وهي
معروفه ليله الهجره ان النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم جعل علي بن ابي طالب ينام في
مضجعه وفي
فراشه
فجاء
الفتيان من القبائل المختلفه وهذا كان
راي ابي
جهل وذلك ان يضربوه ضربه ك الرجل الواحد
فيتفرق دمه في القبائل فلا
يستطيعون الثار اخذ بالثار بثار النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم بدمه يعني عائلته بني هاشم
ف طلع على سطح البيت وراهم ينتظرونه ليلا
نظروا من فتحات الباب تعرفون يعني زمان
الابواب كانت من حديد او من خشب وفيها
فتحات يعني مش مغلقه بالكامل فكانوا
ينظرون ويرون احدا مضطجعا في فراشه هو علي
رضي الله عنه ظنوه النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم وذرى على رؤوسهم شيئا من التراب وفي
بعض الروايات كما جاء عند ابن اسحاق انه
قرا وجعلنا من بين ايديهم سدا ومن خلفهم
سدا فاغشيناهم فهم لا يبصرون ثم انصرف
عليه الصلاه والسلام فلم يروه فلما ان بزغ
الفجر وفطن له قام علي رضي الله عنه من
فراشه واخبرهم ان النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم ليس موجودا ليس ثم
و رد اليهم امانات التي كانت عنده صلى
الله عليه وسلم
لكفار قريش قبل هجرته وبهذا يكتمل هذا
الباب نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يبارك
لنا في القران العظيم اساله تعالى ان
يبارك لنا في سنه نبيه صلى الله عليه وسلم
وان يجعلني واياكم ممن يستمعون الحق
فيتبعون احسنه والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم
على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
والحم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله